this video is sponsored by Squarespace
so very recently I made a video talking
about my top 10 exercises I tried to
make these exercises that I enjoyed that
I like to give to other people that I
think have amazing benefits but I also
try to make it 10 exercises that
together would offer you kind of total
full body workout that went beyond just
the obvious Aesthetics or the mirror
muscles at the same time I tried to pick
10 exercises that you could do mostly
anywhere and with minimal equipment and
I think it was largely successful but I
didn't like doing it it went against my
principles because as you guys know I'm
a training maximalist because I believe
that there are just so many aspects to
Human Performance so I really struggled
I probably cheated I threw in there some
different variations of those exercises
and I even had a bonus exercise at the
end but even then I still felt like I
left a lot on the table it was still
really difficult for me to narrow it
down and yeah I felt it really sucked
leaving some of my favorite moves out
and I was aware of some glaring
omissions so I thought I'd make another
top 10 exercises this being say the same
second half of my top 20 or top 21 or 22
and because these are the slightly less
obvious ones these are the ones that are
really going to take you from you know a
really good comprehensive program to
covering aspects of your performance
that really go overlooked in a lot of
cases without further Ado then let's get
started
so the first exercise that I really
didn't like omitting is the bodyweight
squat I made a whole video on the body
weight squat it's one of my most popular
videos it's one of my favorite movements
I think the bodyweight squat is
fantastic for improving your Mobility I
think it's a fundamental human movement
it's something we all should be able to
do in fact we should find this to be a
comfortable resting position yet a lot
of the population can't get into a
resting squat position at all
[Music]
it's going to improve your back squat if
that's something you're interested in at
the same time it's going to improve your
mathematicism hoping to jump higher and
give you far less chance of injury it's
gonna open up your hips it's going to
improve your ankle Mobility all sorts of
great stuff and something I've really
been enjoying lately is just use these
partial range of motion body weight
squats so I'm just moving up and down in
whatever aspect of the range of motion I
find most difficult like this because if
you're doing a body weight squat then
really the top of that squat
it's not offering you that much
challenge it's basically just standing
up which we do all the time so by moving
just here you're doing all those things
I like trapping the blood and getting it
flowing and causing metabolic stress and
build up but at the same time you're
improving that mobility in a really
mobile and dynamic way and for me that
has done wonders for my Mobility then of
course on top of that you've got all
sorts of great variations that I'm a big
fan of I love goblet squats so grab a
weight a kettlebell in front of you and
do squats that way I really like jumping
squats jump squats leap up into the air
you want to get better at jumping which
is a cool thing to be better at just
jump more anyone who's been using my
super functional training 2.0 program
will know I like to do these Gauntlet
sets these drop sets where I go from
jumping goblet squats to goblet squats
to jump squats to squats it's brutal but
highly effective a very useful tip is
try to lead with your tailbone As you
move into the lower portion of the
bodyweight squat that will help to
reduce Butt Wink so you want to go
straight down with that tailbone like
trying to drive it into the round
next up is glute Bridge honestly there's
not a whole lot to say about the gloopy
bridge I made a whole video on it it's a
simple movement you're lying on the
ground and you're thrusting hips up into
the air making sure to perform a proper
hip hinge and this is what it does it
teaches you to hinge the hips properly
honey come quick the neighbor's in the
garden again
I think he's thrusting the glooper ridge
isn't really necessary if you're already
doing kettlebell swings or some form of
deadlift we had kettlebell swings in the
last video and especially if you're
combining that with some kind of bridge
such as the full bridge but I couldn't
not include it because the glute bridge
is something that has personally helped
me to massively fix my back issues to
better engage my glutes to improve my
performance and it's something I do
program for other people and I still use
it as a part of my warm-up it's a great
way to activate the glute so make sure
that you're then moving correctly
through the rest of the workout
Shadow Boxing might be something you
won't see on many top 10 exercise lists
and that's because you know it's dubious
whether you could really call it an
exercise as such it's more of a series
of different techniques combined it's a
practice a hobby and that's just the
thing you don't have to be an amazing
martial artist I'm certainly not but I
really enjoy this as a way to get my
heart rate up without question it's a
lot more fun than a lot of other forms
of cardio because it's far more
cognitively engaging there's one more to
it because yeah you can hit a bag you
can hit the air and you can just make it
about pumping out reps to burn calories
at the same time you can work on your
Technique you can delve into how to
throw a better Punch or kick or whatever
and doing so makes your martial artist
that's all it takes just for you to ask
questions like how do I get my body to
develop the maximum amount of Power by
driving through the hips Etc it's really
interesting there's so much to learn
here once again we're moving in the
rotational plane but if you're weaving
and dodging from side to side you're
also moving in the frontal plane and if
you're throwing kicks as well then
you've got Mobility work in there too
particularly for the hips it's just
fantastic sparring is the most
cognitively engaging the most exhausting
and the most fun but not everyone will
always have access to a sparring partner
hitting a heavy bag makes it more into a
strength endurance activity better if
you want to build muscle at the same
time and explosiveness Shadow Boxing
though is great because you can do it
anywhere and it's a ton of fun and by
the way guys Grant just made a tutorial
video on Shadow Boxing you've seen how
this guy moves you know it's one of the
best a great place to start out if you
are interested
another one that really pained me to
exclude last time was crawls no two reps
are the same when you're crawling you're
dealing with different terrains
different surfaces you have the regular
hand foot crawl the bear crawl which you
can perform anywhere this will train
your shoulders it drains your pecs your
triceps your core to keep it engaged
your glutes and your calves great for
wrist mobility and strength excellent
for building up to calisthenics moves
it's a fantastic form of strength
endurance and cardio and it's brilliant
for developing hand-eye coordination and
Agility as a contralateral move so so
much going for it
[Music]
we know now he seems to be
cantering up and down like a dog foreign
variations if you do want to train the
pecs for example a bit harder is the
lizard crawl this one is going to bring
you lower to the ground essentially
you're doing one armed push-up so it's
also getting in a bit of additional hip
mobility there so that's fantastic I
also really like crawling uphill and
downhill uphill will train your legs
more downhill will train your shoulders
more and across all kinds of different
terrains like up things that are in your
way if you don't have space to crawl in
your living room great crawl onto an
over the safer crawl onto and over the
table if it won't break and your partner
won't kick you out as a result crawling
along balance beams and along bars this
is fantastic for developing your grip
strength your core stability your
balance and my favorite is to drag a bag
behind me wearing harness and cruel
dragging which makes it far more of an
endurance Challenge and much tougher on
the calves on the shoulders on
everything really even the lats so yeah
crawling is a fantastic exercise another
Dynamic chaotic exercise for building
really durable and resilient strength
really robust movement patterns that
work outside the confines of a linear
and clinical gym
and once we're down here on the ground
let's also talk about the lateral shoot
through I like to call it a kick through
but there's some confusion around the
naming because some people call it
kicksitter kick through and yeah shoot
through most people know what you're
talking about basically it's where
you're in a plank position and you kick
one leg through underneath whilst
raising an arm off the ground I like
this Movement Like many on this combined
list because it's awesome it looks
awesome it feels awesome it's fun to do
do you think we should call somebody
um yeah I think that's reason enough to
do it at the same time though it's
another movement in the transverse plane
and in some ways in the frontal plane so
you know it's not enough to just say I'm
doing my crossbody kettlebell swings
therefore I'm training my transverse
plane you need more than one exercise to
train an entire plane so this is another
great one and this one's more explosive
it's faster if you train with fast
intent which I recommend then you're
going to be more explosive in all kinds
of rotational movements in particular if
I look back at Old footage of me doing
this movement and then footage of me
doing it more recently I can see a
drastic difference and it's translated
to better performance in nearly
everything I do so give that a try it's
also fantastic for shoulder stability
core stability building that nice
oblique look on the side of the ABS to
create more definition highly recommend
this movement and I'll probably make a
highlight on this in the near future
with fast intent
next up
is the humble curl grab away curl it up
I don't have dumbbells here with me at
the moment so I'm making do with a
kettlebell but of course dumbbells or a
barbell would be even better I actually
quite like that version of the movement
though now I'd love to tell you that I
only do Exotic exciting movements and
that something like the curl is you know
beneath me but that just wouldn't be
true I like a lot of bodybuilding
movements and I particularly like the
curls curls are the best way to Target
the biceps if you want hypertrophy there
and let's be honest a lot of us do at
the same time they will also build
strength in the biceps it'll also builds
strength endurance in the biceps both of
which are things that we do actually
need so this is still a functional
movement in particular if you're
interested in wrestling or MMA then big
biceps going to help you to maintain a
choke hold not only to keep it there and
have that strength endurance to not let
go but even to apply pressure by tensing
the bicep on the windpipe so yeah
there's a lovely Charming fact for you
at the same time of course you use your
bicycle from carrying stuff in
particular heavy bags of shopping but
also kids when they're sitting on the
crook of your arm all sorts of stuff you
do use your biceps if you do want to
make this a slightly more functional
movement then what you can do is to
combine supinated underhand curls with
pronated overhand curls and I highly
recommend you do this because that way
you're training not only the forearm
flexors but also the forearm extensors
and in doing that you're going to create
more balance so that you don't end up
with a elbow flare-up lateral
epicondylitis tennis elbow
next up it's the l-sit so I am Denard
between including the l-sit or the
pseudo planche push-up because I'm
really enjoying the pseudo planche
push-up at the moment I'm using it to
train for the straddle plant and for the
first time it feels like I'm close I can
actually do now straddle planche
push-ups and I'm cheating a little bit
because there's a lot of momentum to get
my arms fully locked out straight
position it's only there for a second
but but technically it's a straddle
plant push-up no one's going to take
that away from me so yeah I am really
enjoying that it's great for building
straight arm strength even improving the
bicep sides and the shoulders but I
ultimately decided on the l-sit instead
for a number of reasons so the l-sit
will also strengthen your straight arm
strength the biceps tendon because you
should be keeping your arms locked out
and trying to drill them into the ground
as you go it's also fantastic for the
triceps we don't have much targeting the
triceps on this list at the moment so
that's a great way to build tricep
strength but at the same time also
training your compression strength your
end range strength and Mobility by
lifting the legs up in that position
which is fantastic for all kinds of
other movements and it's something
everyone should be doing and on top of
that you're also getting scapular
depression pushing downwards of the
shoulders and what this does is it
strengthens the lower traps which are so
often overlooked and strengthen the
lower traps will help to prevent you
from having dominant upper traps which
results in you walking around with your
shoulders up by your ears which ain't a
great look also restricts your movement
causes bad posture can cause upper cross
syndrome kyphosis so yeah you want to
train those muscles too and as one of
the only ways to do it that makes the
l-sit just too good to ignore
next up are loaded carries loaded
carries are fantastic for grip strength
for building the traps also great for
hip stabilization because as you're
walking you need to keep your hips nice
and level especially if you're using
this over rough terrain which you can do
for added benefit and in some ways you
could call this the most functional
movement because carrying heavy stuff is
something you actually have to do and of
course it's anti-flexion so yeah carries
are fantastic and for even more benefit
why not do suitcase carries that means
carrying the weight on just one side
keeps carrying that kettlebell up and
down I think he's trying to decide where
to put it maybe and this is going to add
an element of antilateral flexion so
you're trying not to bend to one side
you have to keep your torso even more
stable you have to work even harder with
your hips to keep them stable it's just
a fantastic option again it's something
that nearly anyone can do
[Music]
hang is a fantastic exercise not only
for strengthening the grip but also in
particular for opening up the shoulders
which as I've talked about in the
channel something I've had issues with
it's slow going but I've seen my
handstands improve as a result of doing
this movement it's also really good for
opening up the spine you can help this
along by the way by relaxing the legs on
something which helps you to relax your
whole body more so that your spine is
less rigid allowing for more of that
decompression but either way it's just a
fantastic movement also great for
strength endurance building up willpower
I mean I would like to throw in the
horse stance in here as well maybe I'm
gonna have to do a top 30 exercises who
knows
one more that's fantastic for cardio in
particular that I'd like to include on
this list is skipping skipping or
jumping rope is one of the most
convenient ways to burn lots of calories
to train your aerobic endurance improve
your VO2 max it's something you can do
outside in a garden and you can even get
ropeless skipping ropes and jump in your
living room you can burn even more
calories and build a little bit of
muscle even if you use a weighted rope I
use one from Crossroad full disclosure
this particular video isn't sponsored by
them but I do work with them often but
it does all these other things for you
as well it's great for improving your
Rhythm keeping you light on your feet
which is why boxers love it so much it
actually builds your calves which is a
great bonus because so many people
struggle to grow their carbs and this is
a good way of doing it almost passively
and it improves your ankle stiffness
which translates to Greater
explosiveness in sprinting jumping and
all kinds of other things so yeah
jumping rope is brilliant again I made a
whole video on it and granted a whole
tutorial on it on this channel I highly
recommend you check that out if you want
to get started
so there you go guys that's my list of
my next top 10 favorite exercises
there's loads more I would have liked to
include on this list like the one-legged
Romanian deadlift the Burpee pseudo
planche push-ups the bridge loads more
so let me know if this is something
you'd like to see me follow up on in
future let me know your favorite
exercises in the comments down below and
likewise if you want to see me really
highlight one of these exercises for a
deep dive
[Music]
if you'd like to see a training program
built around many of these exercises
then I highly recommend my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 it comes with over two
hours of instructional footage as well
as an 80 plus page ebook the aim being
to build not only strength but Mobility
endurance even things like reaction
speed Focus bands proprioception if that
sounds cool then check it out either way
thank you so much for watching this one
guys and I'll see you next time bye for
now
foreign
guys feature editing and admin out of
now here to speak to you a bit about
today's sponsor Squarespace so
Squarespace is a website building
platform that makes it extremely easy
for anybody to get up and started with a
website as quite a introverted person I
think a lot and writing is a great way
for me to get my thoughts out onto the
page and to organize through my ideas
and I find the very notion of writing
kind of romantic in the Cinematic sense
I love sitting in a cafe with a coffee
watching the steam rise off of it and
writing and having a platform like a
Blog means that you feel like you're
doing something with that time doing
something creative and potentially
opening up doors and opportunities that
you wouldn't even have thought of
Squarespace is the best way for a lot of
people to do this because you can
genuinely get a website up and running
within 10 minutes using their pre-made
templates that you can then edit to your
heart's desire using their fluid engine
to just intuitively drag and drop
elements exactly where you want them
from there though you can expand your
website as far as you want it to go some
of the biggest brands on the web use
Squarespace so you know there's no
limitations in terms of what you can
achieve you've got things like Advanced
formatting and Publishing tools
Community features with threaded
comments replies and likes you can
manage your members you can create gated
members only content as a form of
Revenue generation you can sell products
from your website using the extensive
e-commerce tools
their social media integration really
anything you can possibly think of and
thanks to the ability to install
additional third-party plugins you can
expand this even further the sky is very
much the limit you can add things to
e-commerce like Inventory management and
global Shipping and all kinds of other
Advanced neat features if you want to
learn more then head over to
squarespay.com and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer to get 10 off your first
domain or website thanks again for
watching guys thanks to Squarespace for
sponsoring
bye for now
foreign
[Music]